well I think it's useful to see the
conventions as a gathering of the news
tribe to which the parties are also
invited they're actually more media
people there than delegates for example
it's not even close it's like 15,000 to
two or three thousand and I think that
there the problem is not that there's
too many journalists there it's that the
ideas that they bear that they bring
with them are just too impoverished so
the whole notion of the horse race press
is that we're going to tell you who's
going to win figure out who's doing
better and explain to you how the
campaigns are trying to win your vote
but this is something that we would be
able to observe on our own if we didn't
have a press trying to tell us who's
going to win and how are they
manipulating us for their vote we would
learn that anyway and so it's not so
much that 15,000 people are going is not
too many and there isn't our better
things they could be doing that's true
but it doesn't explain very much the
real problem is that they go there with
such an impoverished question if their
intention was to tell you who the
Democratic Party actually is in 2008 and
they went in there to find out and told
you as best we can determine this is who
the Democrats are if they wanted to
answer we're do the Democrats stand on
executive power and inform us by doing a
saturation reporting exercise while
there well that would at least be an
idea right and so it's it's more that
it's that
problem with the horse race press is
that it is completely in love which is
own agenda lessness and advertising its
agenda lessness in a sort of endless
succession of reports but we already get
that message Brian Williams looks into
the camera in these ads that run in New
York he says I'm not for any particular
candidate I'm for New York and I want to
say to him you know Brian I get that I
get that already you know you're not
rooting for anybody you're not trying to
elect the reds or the blues but you must
have something better in mind for me
than just that
you